-Looking good, bud.
Looking good.
Welcome back to the show.
I'm happy you're here.
You have --
the album is finally out.
-Yeah.
-It is out -- "D-DAY."
-"D-DAY."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The documentary is out.
The global tour
just kicked off last week.
How does it all --
[ Cheers and applause ]
How does it all feel?
Yeah.
They love you.
I love you.
Before you were known as Suga,
I read this somewhere --
tell me if this is true --
you were a food delivery --
delivery guy?
[ Laughter ]
You were very good?
Why?
[ Laughter ]
What made you good?
You just...
[ Laughter ]
That helps.
Yeah, but now
you're who you are.
Congratulations.
I mean, you're -- you're --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm a Knick fan.
And I saw you yesterday
at the playoffs.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, there you are.
This is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Looking good.
Exciting news.
You were named
an NBA ambassador.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What -- What does that mean?
What will you be doing
as part of that?
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
Did you want to be --
Did you want to be
a professional basketball
player ever?
[ Laughter ]
Are you the best
basketball player in BTS?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Are you kidding me?
-[ Laughing ]
Really?
-I think your name actually --
is it true? --
came from basketball?
Right?
How you got Suga?
-Yeah.
Shooting guard -- shoo-ga.
-Shooting and guard,
so "shoo-ga."
-"Shoo-ga."
-Yeah.
And then,
can you explain Agust D?
-Yep.
-How? I don't --
-Reverse.
D.T. Suga.
[ Cheering ]
-Oh.
-Yeah.
My hometown name is Daegu.
-Ah, D.T. Suga.
-Daegu town Suga.
Reverse.
Agust D.
-So that's your hometown, D.T.?
-Yeah, D.T.
-D.T. So, D.T. Suga.
D.T. Suga is pretty cool, too.
-Mm-hmm.
-But you want to go Agust D?
-No. Drive-through.
D.T.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, yeah. Drive-through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I understand, yeah.
Yeah, I understand.
But when -- when you're --
When you're Agust D, are you
different than when you're Suga?
You are.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You can call me Agust D
or Suga or Yoongi.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You answer to all that.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's a great record.
Congratulations on this.
What does --
What does "D-DAY" mean to you?
Wow. It's a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And the song you're
performing tonight is "Haegeum."
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not yet.
Soon. Soon.
Not yet, not yet.
Soon, soon, soon.
But you were telling me
that "Haegeum" has two meanings.
-Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
-What are the meanings
of Haegeum?
Do you --
Do you know how to play haegeum?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you sure?
Because...
-Wow.
I stole it
from your dressing room.
No, no.
[ Laughter ]
[ Scraping ]
Give me that, give me that,
give me that.
Yeah, yeah, no.
[ Laughter ]
Let me try.
Quest, can I get a beat?
♪♪
[ Light scraping ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Off-key notes play ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait!
I got some sound!
-Yeah.
-I got --
-You did.
-You kicked off your
giant world tour last week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Look at this right here.
This is you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How did it feel
to be back on stage?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The documentary I enjoyed,
it's on Disney+.
It is called
"Suga: Road to D-DAY."
-Yeah.
-And we get to see
behind the scenes
of how this album
was put together.
Did it bother you having
all the cameras around,
or are you used to it?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, you're right. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I do want to show everyone
a clip from the documentary.
Here's a peek at
"Suga: Road to D-DAY."
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Suga is a musical genius.
When I've listened
to his music on his own,
he's always doing something
I would never expect.
So I always expect the highest
bar from Suga.
-[ Rapping in Korean ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you were...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
You're nice enough to be
performing live
to close our show out.
And let me tell you,
it is a performance
like you've never seen.
It is unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it.
There's lasers, there's dancing,
there's everything.
It is so good.
It is like a Grammy performance.
So thank you for being here
and doing that.
It means a lot to us.
Thank you for doing it.
But I was asking you earlier,
do you have any traditions
or any superstitions
or something you do
before every show
even to relax, and you --
Can you tell everyone what
you -- what you told me?
[ Laughter, cheers ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I figured, hey...
-Oh!
-It's not vinegar. That's real.
-It's real.
-It's real. Congratulations.
-Yeah.
-Good luck.
Thank you for being here.
-Yeah.
Suga, everybody!
Agust D!
[ Cheers and applause ]
When we come back,
Suga, a.k.a. Agust D,
is performing a song
from his new album, "D-DAY."
Stick around, everybody.
Whoo!